thomas bonsoir alors une particularité 2
ministre s'exprimait ce soir où une
conférence de presse commune qui aura
duré une trentaine de minutes au cours
de laquelle les deux ministres on
parlait à peu près chacun à la moitié du
temps l'idée c'était évidemment
d'associer l'aspect sanitaire à l'aspect
économique de la crise puisque olivier
rend le ministre de la santé était aux
côtés de bruno le maire ministre de
l'économie et des finances et de la
relance alors olivier ferrand a sans
surprise annoncé des mauvaises nouvelles
pour commencer avec une situation qui
continue de se dégrader selon le
ministre de la santé donc quatre villes
lille grenoble lyon et saint-etienne
passe désormais en zone d' alerte
maximale ce sera à partir de samedi
matin cela implique notamment la
fermeture des bars et des restrictions
dans les restaurants avec des mesures
sanitaires renforcés
dijon et clermont-ferrand sont pour leur
part passés en alerte renforcée et puis
enfin toulouse et montpellier il ya une
situation inquiétante danser à deux
villes et le ministre de la santé se
donne quelques jours d'observation pour
surveiller les indicateurs les
différends qui a annoncé également que
les élus locaux avaient été consultés
pour l'évolution de ces zones dallaire
pour les villes dont je viens de vous
parler c'est évidemment en référence
notamment à l'imbroglio qui avait eu
lieu à marseille il y a de cela quelques
semaines olivier roncq a également tenu
à donner quelques points positifs lors
de cette conférence de presse il y a des
signes d'amélioration avec notamment une
inflexion positive
alice bordeaux rennes ou encore à aix
marseille propose d'écouter ou l'hiver
malgré ces situations difficiles et
c'est annonce difficile
je tiens à préciser qu'il ya aussi des
signes d'amélioration dans plusieurs
endroits du territoire national il faut
s'y prendre de bonne nouvelle quand on
peut les observer signe que les mesures
que nous mettons en oeuvre pour lutter
contre la circulation du virus et que
les mesures qui sont prises d'ailleurs
par les élus locaux de même pour freiner
la diffusion du virus sont efficaces
ainsi la nièvre et le morbihan keatley
départements classés en zone d' alerte
et on enregistre une amélioration
sensible de la situation sanitaire
nice à bordeaux une inflexion positive
également être observée à rennes ainsi
qu'à aix marseille
je le dis tout de suite avant de crier
victoire il faut avoir suffisamment de
recul être sûr que dans la durée
la circulation du virus se réduit et que
dans la durée
l'impact sanitaire sur les hôpitaux se
réduit il n'y a donc pas à date de
bascule dans une zone d' alerte
inférieurs pour les villes que j'ai
cités mais nous surveillons cela
quotidiennement et nous espérons pouvoir
annoncer des bonnes nouvelles peut-être
la semaine prochaine
et puis c'est donc bruno le maire le
ministre de l'économie qui a pris la
parole un ministre qui a lui-même été
atteint par le col idée qui a détaillé
des mesures pour et bien protéger les
salariés et les entreprises
ils vont le gouvernement va protéger les
entreprises les entreprises et les
salariés tant que la crise sanitaire
sera là c'est ce qu'a annoncé bruno le
maire ce soir avec notamment l'ajout de
75 mille entreprises qui pourront
désormais bénéficier du fonds de
solidarité alors vous l'avez compris la
volonté du gouvernement était donc de ne
pas communiquer uniquement sur des
mauvaises nouvelles mais l'information
essentielles à retenir c'est toutefois
la dégradation de la situation dans un
certain nombre de villes avec notamment
des services de réanimation qui
reçoivent à nouveau de nombreux malades
du cornât virus c'est le cas par exemple
en ile de france avec plus de 40 % des
lits de réanimation qui sont
actuellement occupées et d'ailleurs la
situation dans la région inquiète
particulièrement les autorités puisque
ce matin le directeur de l'agencé
régionale de santé
il est à craindre je cite une marée très
forte de nouveaux malades dans les
hôpitaux franciliens pour autant il ya
donc aussi des signes d'amélioration et
olivero indique qu'il n'est pas pour
l'heure question d'instaurer des
restrictions de déplacement en france
est une question qui revient souvent
puisque on approche des vacances de la
toussaint même si le ministre de la
santé
certes ne prévoit pas de restriction
déplacement il appelle toutefois à la
plus grande prudence
merci beaucoup thomas abonnés pour
toutes ces précisions